[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
testing
[Music]
yes love it might check first thing
so again welcome to the table we're glad
that you're here if you're joining us
online
as well we are thrilled that you're here
as well you're very much a part of this
community too
uh just real quick one announcement
there's nothing major to kind of go over
there's not a lot of things
right now that are going on but in two
weeks so not next sunday but the sunday
following before memorial day weekend
uh we basically are having a little bit
of a break um so
we will not be having a sunday service
that particular sunday
um just kind of gives everybody a little
bit of a break um who especially
who or people are volunteering and
helping giving other time
and also it gives you a chance to just
kind of focus on family since that's a
nice
good weekend kind of be able to do so
all right so i'm going to
start us off in worship with a quick
prayer
lord thank you so much for just bringing
us all together
thank you for the rain um thank you for
uh just this ability to come and worship
and appraise you
and to connect um with other people i
pray you open up our hearts
our minds to um just where we are to
where you want us to be
and help us to receive what you need us
to receive for this week
and christ's saying i pray amen
[Music]
i'm not
okay i wasn't actually expecting that to
come out of
really so
i have to nerd out for just a second
with you guys because i learned this
thing this weekend
and it is i don't know why
something small like this blowing my
mind but it's really blowing my mind so
we've been pulling out these
trees that died from snowmageddon it was
so sad they were beautiful trees that
had lived
a very good life behind our pool and
we're having to pull them out
so that we can plant new ones back there
and i learned this thing that if you
just like grind up the stump or
you know hack it down to the very base
like against the ground
and then find a new spot beside it
somewhere to plant a new tree
that the decomposition of the old tree
that is dead
will trump the new growth beside it
like it requires the same nutrients the
same
ingredients to decompose as the new life
does to grow
i didn't realize this and so i just keep
thinking about like all weekend as we
hack ourselves through these humongous
monster routes
it has been so very taxing
but i just keep having this thought
about like how that translates into life
and how even whenever we're pursuing
growth in an area
new things wanting to be our best selves
you know wanting to be more like christ
if we don't take the time to go uproot
and
unearth the pain from our past or to
face
the ugliness of you know i don't know
wrong choices things that we need to
make right relationships that we've let
go untended to if we're not willing to
go back and face those
that that death and decay
will trump eventually how far we are
able to grow
and it's just like i don't know one of
those things that keeps ringing in my
ears like what are the things in my life
that i still need to face or might you
know what i mean have been ignoring for
so long thinking
well we cut them down to the ground you
can't even really see them you know
or i meet somebody new they don't even
really know about that thing but
until i'm able to really face it
there is a limit to how much i'm able to
grow you know
how much freedom i'm able to access in
christ
how much i'm able to become more and
more like him so
anyway in that spirit this song is
talking about
inviting jesus to come tear down walls
um so that we can really meet with him
so that we can really be transformed by
him
and i just thought that might be a
helpful mental picture
if you guys are as intrigued by that
little factoid as i am um just going
into it like all right god
i really want to face the things that
need to be uprooted
so that i can have new life in you
so um all right let's get started
it's just the two of us tonight so we're
gonna keep it nice and intimate
come tear down the walls i've built up
every wall i've built up every wall
deserve every piece of my heart
every piece of my heart every piece
let's sing that one more time
come tear down the walls i've built
up every wall i've built up
every wall i've built up
you deserve every piece of my heart
every piece of my heart every piece of
my heart
lord i'm trusting that you
are a faithful father
and all that you have it is good
you're a generous giver
with love like no other come and break
through to me
come tear down the walls
[Music]
you deserve every piece of my heart
every piece of my heart every piece
of my heart lord
i am trusting that you are
a faithful father and all that you
have it is good you're a generous giver
with love like no other you come and
bake
through to me over and over and over
again i am bringing my heart to you
with open hands closer and closer you
drawing me and
as the depths of my heart lay before you
again
over and over and over
again i am bringing my heart to you
with open hands closer and closer
[Music]
again
come tear down the walls i've built up
every wall i've built up every wall
i've built up you
deserve every piece of my heart
every piece of my heart every piece of
my heart
everything
all of me
[Music]
okay
all right we're going to go ahead and
move into our prayers of the people
um so if you've been here you know kind
of how it goes i'm going to
say a short prayer and then i'm going to
open it up to you guys
to join in and share um anyone that you
would like us to hold in prayer before
god or maybe a situation or moment a
people group
we ask that you just say their name
instead of giving details since
you know we want to respect their
privacy but this
is a time for us to share the burdens
that we're carrying and the people that
were carrying with us
together and lift them up before god and
invite him into those spaces
if you're watching online please just
leave a comment
and we will try karen's going to be
watching and
we'll try to go over any of those that
get listed
um at the end of our prayer um
all right i'm gonna go ahead and open
this up
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community
and all of those who live in them we
pray
to you for the good earth that you have
given us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it we pray
to you for those who travel
on land sea or air we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the widow
and orphan
for the injured and suffering we pray to
you
for the poor and oppressed the
unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you for we know that you love
us
and that you hear us and so we lift
these names and situations
up to you now
[Music]
roy
david
[Music]
roy
ashley
[Music]
all right
come online
for these names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
you unravel me
with a melody
[Music]
you surround me with
a song
[Music]
of deliverance
of our enemies till
all my fears
are gone and
i'm no longer
[Music]
i'm no a slave to fear
i am a child
of god
from my mother's womb
[Music]
you have chosen me
you love horns called my name
i've been born again
into your family
your blood flows through my veins
i'm no longer a slave to fear
[Music]
no i am a child
of god i'm no longer
safe to fear
no i am a child
of god sing that one more time i'm no
longer
a slave to fear
though i am a child
of god
[Music]
know i am a child of god
oh
[Music]
you split the sea so i could walk
so i could stand and sing
i am a child of god
who you split the sea
so i could walk right
[Music]
you rescued me so i could stand and see
i am a child of god
i am a child
of god
[Music]
oh to break every chain
break every chain break every chain
[Music]
break every day
there is power in the name of jesus
to break every chain break every chain
break every chain
break every chain break every chain
[Music]
i just wanted to share um
this week as we were practicing through
this song
um there there's a line that we're about
to sing that says there's an army rising
up
and i to say at one point in my life i
sang this song and that part would come
and i would think
of images like if you just pray hard
enough maggie
then there will be a spiritual battle
that you will win and if you just grit
your teeth and
you know try to be as spiritual as
possible
then um you know there will be that
spiritual army that rises up on your
behalf and you will become this mighty
giant of faith and today as i was
singing
through this song um a totally different
image popped into my head
earlier this week we had a friend who
was just going through some really hard
stuff and sharing
just really vulnerably about
some of the transitions in their life
and a lot of them
are related to chains that they have
carried and
bondage that they've been wrapped up in
and they're starting to try and step
into that identity of being unashamed
and um as they shared it we got
to have just the honor and the privilege
of standing beside them and praying
and um being part of the process
of watching those chains break loose
being just a very very tiny part of that
picture
but it occurred to me today as i was
singing this
i was singing there's an army rising up
to break every chain and i thought
oh my god the army is the body of christ
it's not like a spiritual army that
we're you know waiting to ascend from on
high that
the army is us and we rise up
and we speak out the word of truth to
people
and we watch chains broken like as
people are able to walk into their full
identity and kind of
reclaim everything that's maybe been
stolen from them
whether it's from other people and what
other people have done to them
or whether it's spiritual battles or
whether it's you know lies that they
believed
themselves we get to be the army that
rises up around them and says
that's not true that is not true
whatever has been holding you back or
keeping you captive
so i just wanted to share that because
as we sing it
i want it to kind of at least for myself
be a declaration
i want to be part of an army
that looks at people who have felt
worthless or ashamed or fearful
and to tell them you're a child of god
you have nothing to be ashamed of
you are loved just as you are you are
valuable you are validated here
and um i just invite you guys to
kind of step into that calling with me
that's who we are as believers the word
talks about
us holding up the word of life to one
another
and that's what those moments are about
so um
with what mindy shared earlier this is
kind of
a chance for us to step into that for
one another even not just for ourselves
but for one another so
there's an army right
up
there's an army rising
up there's an
army right
up to break
every chain break every chain
break every chain
to break every chain break every chain
break every chain sing that again
there's an army rising up
whoa there's an army
rising up
[Music]
to break every chain break every chain
break every chain
break every chain break every chain
[Music]
to break every chain break every chain
break every chain
break every chain break every chain
[Music]
you split the sea so i could walk
right through it my fears are drown
in perfect love
you rescued me so i could stand and sing
i am a child
of god
you split the sea so i could walk
right through it my fears
i am a child
of god
they're a slave to fear
know i am a child of god
one last time i'm no longer
[Music]
no i am a child of god
i'm no longer a slave to fear
i am the child
of god
thank you god that you believe in us
even when we've lost our belief in
ourself
and that you surround us with people who
call us forward
that you've given us community where we
can walk in truth
of who you've created us to be
where there is grace and forgiveness and
redemption
jesus keep calling us forward into
bigger and better things
[Music]
things that are more like you things
that look like the gospel here on earth
we love you and we pray that the rest of
this time together we would have open
ears and hearts to hear your words to us
in jesus name amen
thank you guys for worshiping with us
and if you will just turn to the people
around you
and wave say hello really quickly then
we'll go ahead and get started with our
message
um this one ran out of batteries i think
actually so this one won't do you any
good
check check there we go sweet
all right flawless here at the table
we're flawless
no um god is good god's good so
y'all you made it you braved the weather
thank you for being here i thought i
might i might be alone or at least here
i knew we'd have people online hey
online people
um but i didn't know of anyone of you so
thank you for being here
um it is man it's just great it's great
to be here it's great to
um just to worship with you all and
thank you maggie mindy for leading us in
that time
beautiful my heart is full very very
full
so um i did want to just make sure i
already said hello but i want to make
sure i welcome
love you lots thank you for being with
us um
and uh let's see we are in this is part
five y'all
five of six next week will be our last
week in this series um
and uh then in june
um we'll have actually a number of like
guest speakers and and some folks
um which i think will be really cool we
have some really cool people sure i'm
very excited
um so uh but we're in part five and so
kind of you you know um you know the
kind of premise of the series
most of you know it by now it's new
normal and uh kind of our big idea
is it's just that although the last you
know 12 13 14 months has been
not by a long stretch um the the
beautiful part is that
kind of hiding within it is an
opportunity because our normal got all
flipped upside down tables turned just a
mess and we're like oh my gosh and
because of that we
um you know we had a lot of new
experiences
um often challenging ones that kind of
revealed things to us the
to kind of use the language of the bible
you know our lives their
things were shaken and and when you
experience
a shaking um it's like you kind of see
what remains
what's you know kind of firm and strong
and then what
is uh just didn't last didn't make it
and when i say things
i'm thinking everything from um you know
our even identities um ideas we had
about ourselves or the world or god or
whatever
um even practices rhythms of life
and you know all that just got shaken
and so it's it's kind of a prime time i
think now
um to start reflecting on all right what
did i experience
what was beautiful what was good what
was true from this last season what got
kind of
to mess with my metaphor switch him up
what got refined by fire
and what got just burned up it just
didn't didn't even make it
uh and so that's kind of what this
series about is helping us in that kind
of reflection
um process so with that in mind the
title of my message tonight
is just one word i'm fond of one word
titles y'all don't figure this out yet
um it's victim victim in our primary
text
is going to be john chapter 5 verses 1-6
and before i read it i'll say i think
you know
this past season i think we've had a
real temptation at least i have
to kind of um to kind of tell myself a
story about
how um victimized i was by all the
circumstances and the challenges of the
last year
and so that's kind of the big idea that
we'll be kind of unpacking
so this story from john chapter 5
this is a story about jesus and so it
says this sometime later
jesus went up to jerusalem for one of
the jewish festivals
now there is in jerusalem near the
sheepgate a pool
which in aramaic is called bethesda and
which is surrounded by
five covered colonnades it's these sort
of like
pillars with some kind of roofing over
almost like a tint like structure
it's kind of a picture so it's sort of a
you know inside outside
area sort of open you know not walls but
pillars and
kind of a courtyard that's kind of
backing up to this this famous
pool um five covered colonnades verse
three here
a great number of disabled uh disabled
people
used to lie uh the blind the lame
the paralyzed and one who was there had
been an
invalid this is someone who who can't
move well and probably couldn't walk
for 38 years
when jesus saw him lying there and
learned that he had been in this
condition for a long time
he asked him do you want
to get well
do you want to get well
i um i wonder if this question
check check check check check test test
test test
am i good all right sweet oh no
it's a green i got a green light all
right now we're good
okay effortless tonight
ever fire
[Laughter]
um so okay so uh
this i so i remember the first time i
read this passage and we're not the
first time i'll say the first time it
really jumped you know it's jumped off
the page you mean it's easy to kind of
read
bible stories and just kind of like okay
yeah yeah but i remember the first time
this just
the question jumped out at me because i
just thought
what what kind of a ridiculous question
is that
like i mean has a more insane question
ever been asked
like i mean dude i'm gonna write like
empathize for a moment you know
like put yourself in the place of this
man like 38 years
i mean who knows maybe he's 38 years old
maybe his whole life maybe he was maybe
he's 48 it happened when he was 10 and
we don't know the exact story but
almost four decades he's been in this
kind of place
and uh and i mean just imagine the
atmosphere there
like he's there in this this kind of um
next to this pool with i mean who knows
hundreds of other people i mean
this is not a great life
and so there he is do you want to get
well i mean just
put yourself in his place do do i
do i want to get well what kind of a
question do
do the blind want to see do the deaf
want to hear do the lame want to walk do
the paralyzed want to move
uh yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes jesus
this is what is what is going on like
what kind of a crazy question is this
um now here's the thing uh jesus
is of course uh the son of god the
wisest
most um insightful
kind of spiritually in tune person to i
think ever walked the face of the earth
and so when he asks a question it's
never on accident
it is never like a mistake or like oh
sorry social faux pas
you know uh no no no he's
something something was going on here so
something i think he
sensed i think he sensed it actually
there
there was a bit of a question in this
man's heart and mind that
does he actually want to get well i i
think that was like an
actual live question um
and so as as jesus is there he's i think
what he's doing he's
he senses something needs to be drawn
out
something needs to be exposed
there's something going on here
um and so jesus was
willing to ask the hard question
um i i've i heard that um
with a broken bone that
uh when it when it breaks that you know
in like modern times of course everyone
rushes the hospital and it's like you
get it all fixed up and set and then
casted and you know it's like all those
steps
but um what happens naturally if you if
you
kind of just leave the bone for like a
few weeks maybe months because of the
stem cells and various things in the
bone
do you know kind of what happens to the
bones like they well i'm not talking
about a hairline fracture i'm talking
about like a
snap it will actually the bones
reconnect
they will like literally fuse back to
one another
um but the thing is uh it's
it's i mean it's better than them not
connecting because at least you can kind
of
you know walk kind of but the thing is
that that person is kind of doomed to
forever walk with a limp and you'll
likely live with chronic pain
so it's sort of a healing but it's kind
of like not really
um which is why if you go to the for
example the doctor
um and for whatever the story is i don't
know on what
you know why on earth you wouldn't go
get your bone set right away but let's
just say
for the second argument that that's what
happened to you is this your legal sage
you're like right in it it broke
and so you go to the doctor it's been
like weeks and the bone has kind of
um they called a mal a male union a
dysfunctional connection
that if that happens you go to the
doctor
and what will that doctor do do you know
what they'll do
they re-break the bone i mean just kind
of think of this like you're going to
the doctor
to be healed and the doctor's like well
first things first we got to break this
bone again
it's like no no i didn't i came to you
to be healed what are you doing
now i i think this is um kind of an apt
insight
because jesus is the great physician and
i think what he's doing not literally of
course
but i think kind of spiritually
emotionally
he saw that that as a certain kind of
dysfunctional quote unquote healing
a kind of way of coping had kind of um
happened inside this man and so jesus um
in his love and mercy and compassion um
cares more about the long-term growth in
maturity
of in in healing of this man than his
short-term comfort and ease
and this by the way this is what love
does love cares more for the
for the long-term growth and maturity of
a person
than simply their short-term you know
comfort and so i think
jesus jesus knows this
and so with six words do you want to get
well
i think again not not physically but but
i think emotionally spiritually
i think i think jesus is re-breaking
the bone um again in his mercy and
compassion
not not be i don't think he was trying
to shame the man um i don't think it was
like i'm gonna teach you a
a lesson you know in kind of a
moralistic sense i don't think that's
what it was i think
i think what it was jesus is willing to
do the
short term um to ask the question that
hurts
to bring the later deeper healing does
that does that kind of make sense
are we tracking so far cool okay good
um and there is
there is some backstory um that i think
would be kind of helpful as we're trying
to understand
this you know bethesda and all this so
there was a legend in fact if you're
reading in your actual physical bible
some bibles have verse four others don't
and the version we read it had a little
bracket just had four
and immediately jump to five is because
verse four is kind of a later insertion
still quite early um but at some point
people added a little verse to kind of
explain what is going on
because here's the question why are all
these people hanging out that pool
right like what are they all they're
just kind of chilling maybe it was nice
or
the tent thing it's kind of covered
shady what is going on
uh so here this is verse four um
that there was kind of a legend that
built up around bethesda
and the legend went uh that
occasionally an angel would stir
up the waters
and so all of a sudden you would see
these ripples like this miraculous kind
of no one's touching the water but all
of a sudden ripple ripple ripple ripple
and it starts lapping against the sides
of the pool and that
set off the great scramble
as this decimated struggling
hurting mass of humanity
would star i mean i'm imagining it was
not pretty
like probably physical and people were
desperate to get to the pool
because legend had it the first person
to the pool was what
healed first person in the pool
was healed so this man it doesn't say
how long he's been by the pool
presumably a long time maybe
maybe 38
years wait do doing what what's going on
there he is he's waiting for his healing
he's waiting for his life
to begin and so jesus
asks the question that breaks the man's
heart he asks the question
that draws him out that exposes what's
inside of him
do you want to get well are you really
ready for everything to change
because well and again that may sound
like a crazy question at first
but if you think about it it's actually
not a crazy question at all
why because when you've lived
with a wound of some sort and i'm
thinking here not just a physical like
ouch you know wound a broken
boner i'm thinking um this could be
emotional
this could be relational um some sort of
abuse in your past
addiction in your past some kind of
trauma when you've lived with a wound
here's kind of the the formula that i
see
when you have a wound to cope with it
and this is i think true of everyone
we tell a story we tell a story about
the wounding
in out of the story we start to shape
an identity can you see this right human
to be human is to tell stories i mean
think of it like you get together what
do you do
like for dinner you just tell stories
the whole time
right even think of the chatter in your
head like all day they say um
i've read this recently i read it on the
internet so i know it's true
um it was it said uh that we have
something like a hundred thousand
thoughts a day
a hundred that means every ten days
a million thoughts like that's crazy
and what are we often doing in our minds
what are we doing
all day telling the what
telling the story right telling various
stories
and i think often um maybe for you i
don't know how often maybe 10 times a
day 100
we often are circling around some prior
wound
right some some emotional trauma some um
some struggle
some wound that we tell a story and then
what's the piece with
identity well if you tell yourself a
story long enough and
enough times i mean it becomes a part of
who
like a part of who you are in fact you
know what's fascinating
is even families kind of get like
family stories don't we and i mean not
necessarily in the good way like we have
hopefully your family had the good
stories
you know the whole time old uncle jim
did the funny thing or you know whatever
but but there's also the the not so good
stories
like there's there's this story i'm
thinking um the past few
weeks i've been reflecting on like some
of the stories i've heard families tell
you know and like there's these
these things from the past like well
when when
this family we used to be on the right
track
we used to have money like we used to be
good but then when your grandpa left
your grandma
uh that's when everything started going
downhill for us
right and maybe even as like a 10 year
old or 12 or 15 like he started to pick
up
on these oh that's the trauma oh it's
when grandpa bill
left you know grandma jeanine and that
was the moment
that all of a sudden we started to like
that's the and that's the story and even
it gets passed down generationally this
is the story
and then it becomes what and this is who
we are this is our story
are you tracking um i was thinking even
uh a folks i talked to someone they had
failed out i think it was their first
semester of college
and so what they told me was well you
see here's the thing brett
what i learned from that moment was that
i'm not book smart
that was their little phrase book smart
in fact our family like we're just not
really
book smart like we have
other kind of smarts but you know we're
just we're just not really like
college kind of people
can you hear can hear it's not even
simply like oh i have different passions
and interests and you know i'm going to
go this direction
because i'm not saying like everyone
must go to college and you must do that
that's not the point
right the point is there's a certain a
failure a hurt a wound
you tell yourself a story to cope but
then before you know it
it's now it's not just a thing that
happened in your past
now it's like an essential part of who
you are uh and this can be i mean all
sorts of things it can be past
failures you have a business that fails
and you tell the story of like look i'm
just
i'm just that guy like i'm just kind of
a failure that's just kind of who i
don't know why it's like everything i
touch it just
falls apart right can you hear it's a
story
um even you know parents i think play a
huge role in this not only in the
storytelling
but even in our experience right of like
if maybe you had
messed up you know not not a good
childhood and so what's the story like
i had these parents they were i mean
fill in the blank right abusive
neglectful hurtful maybe physically
abusive or emotionally or verbally or
whatever it is
and that and
and they didn't even really train me
right they didn't show me how to live
and so brett i am who i am today
because of them
can you hear can you hear the steps
there because i'm not just to be clear
i'm not saying like
how dare you ever complain or say that
you were victimized by
well no of course like no these stories
are real
like i'm not saying the story don't ever
tell a story that's right no
that's to be human is to process our
pain to tell the story what i'm saying
is you be very careful of the story
you're telling
be very very careful because it's going
to shape
what your identity it's going to shape
your yeah it's going to shape your
future who you become
in powerful powerful ways
in fact i think you get kind of echoes
of this in this
text because remember jesus question the
question was
do you want to get well which is i mean
probably answer is yes or no um but
notice
notice what the man says verse 7
and i'll paraphrase a little bit because
you can read it it's up on the screen
but sir the invalid replied
i have no one to help me
um you see all these other people jesus
all these other people around me
like they have they have people that
love them
they have people that support them they
have people that are there for them they
have like a community and friends like
real friends and family
and um i don't i don't have that
jesus i don't have that kind of love and
support
uh and don't get me wrong i mean i've
tried i've tried i've tried to get the
pool but here's the thing
like every time like i try like there's
always someone faster there's always
someone stronger there's always someone
like more quick
like they're they're preventing me from
getting the to the healing i need can
you
can you kind of hear what i mean again
jesus didn't ask him like okay so tell
me your story like why haven't you been
healed after 38 years you've been laying
here man waiting for your life to begin
what's going on
that was not jesus question the question
was do you want to be healed
do you want to get well and he's like
well let me tell you i've been here
38 can you hear like it's almost like a
script
the guy has recited kind of over and
over
it's this i mean what's he doing he's
telling the story it's wound
its story it's identity um in other
words
i think we're all very tempted to
construct this sort of false sense of
self
on the sinking sands of victimhood
right and again the problems my point is
not to minimize the wounding itself
we've got to be careful of the story
that we tell and the identity that we
begin to derive from it and i think here
we're walking a very very fine line
um because the stories as we tell them
they're
almost exactly the same there's just a
few little wrinkles that make
a story kind of spiritually healthy or
unhealthy here's probably a very
unhealthy version it would go something
like this
so i've had some really terrible things
happen to me
in my life um
some tremendous injustices
and honestly those moments have become
the absolute defining moments of
my life my identity my
name my name is ruined
my name is helpless
my name is hopeless
my name is victim this is who i am
can you see the wound the story identity
but there's another way to tell the
story
so i've had some incredibly
difficult circumstances in my life
um terrible things have happened to me
some some tremendous injustices
and yet all along the path
god has loved me and been faithful to me
and there's always been at least one
person
that has loved me and been praying for
me
in those moments cancer
abuse job loss
bankruptcy death
those moments do
not define me
because my name
is courageous and my name
is strength in my name
is lovable in my name
is victorious
that's the difference same wound
same circumstances
similar story but
with a twist and i think
at our best that's where we are
you know at least at my best that's
where i am
um at my worst not so much
you know i've been i've been thinking
about um everything we've kind of gone
through as a church
and um i remember in the early months of
the pandemic
oh i was so tempted
towards a story of victim
and i'm thinking in terms of the table
because we launch out and it's like yeah
it's going great
and then four months in and then the
pandemic hits and a few i'm like oh my
gosh
on online online church you ever heard
of such a thing as a long-term solution
like oh my gosh i was so
it was honestly it just kind of felt
overwhelming like now i have to
learn a whole new oh oh my gosh
and i did i struggled i mean
not every day but almost it was really
hard but over time you know god started
to show me brett you got to tell a new
story my friend
because here's the truth i am so
grateful that we launched
in november of 2019.
so grateful because we got four months
four
months to come together to form
connections
to see each other you know face to face
and then we got to transition online
because of that
now we have like this whole online
community hello
that we hello over there over there this
camera that we know
and love and now it's like the best of
both worlds like what an amazing thing
god has done praise the lord
hallelujah right it's i mean what's
going with the same circumstances
i mean just we gotta i gotta i'll just
put on me
maybe y'all would agree we gotta tell a
better story i gotta tell a better story
and in one that doesn't place me as the
victim
but as one that has faith and trusts god
that god is doing a beautiful
thing in my life in our midst in your
life
amen amen you know i was thinking um
as we kind of transition into communion
um about jesus and what a
like if you think of the cross that was
such a moment of
a victim in a way i mean my goodness
that's he's
he really is sort of the archetypal
almost picture of
victim hanging on a cross and yet what's
so beautiful
is that what is resurrection it's
it is i think it's a step it's like a
step of victory and it's
it's almost him refu even the way jesus
refused to um condemn those who killed
him
extended forgiveness to them the people
thinking of the roman soldiers and
others who killed
plus the disciples who abandoned and yet
in resurrection
he forgives it's almost like he's taking
this step to refuse
that identity of victim instead as a
resurrected one he becomes the victor
and i think that's what a profound
picture
um and i think such an encouragement for
us you know as
as christians like that's the picture
we're living into and i think that's
such a beautiful reminder of what
communion is about and that's kind of
the mindset i want as we go into this
i want you to kind of carry with you uh
is that
that kind of remembering jesus as yes
the victim but the victim who became
the victor by the power of god
um so we're going to do communion and
it's a little bit different as you can
see we got the
things on the on the chairs and for
those on the line
um i think james probably mentioned to
you all that um if you could grab like a
cracker
or grape juice or you know whatever wine
if you don't want one that's great like
just whatever you have at your house and
uh and kind of together
um we are gonna participate in communion
now i have two
two things um one is we practice what's
called an open table
here meaning if you're here tonight and
you want to participate
you just go right ahead don't worry if
you're like i don't know am i really
have enough faith
or you know or mean jesus good you know
just if you want to connect with the
crucified and resurrected one
um then you just go for it
and um second i know not everyone may be
incredibly you know
familiar with this what's called a
sacrament or this practice of communion
um and so um a quick
kind of background is basically that
um on the night well i'll put it this
way
there's really two things we do in
communion first is we remember second we
participate
so the participation is the sense of
when we um come here and we connect and
we we take the bread in the cup
we are through the holy spirit we are
connecting with
christ in this beautiful way how exactly
it works
i do not know that is the mystery god is
present
and we're connecting with him so there's
participation second there's remembrance
you remember um jesus says over and over
remember me
remember me in just a moment i'll say
that um as i'm quoting jesus and
that's that is we're remembering again
the story
that we're living into so um
with that in mind the way this works on
the top you probably saw there's like a
thin little film and that kind of does
the bread
and then there's the the larger top is
the the cup
so that's kind of how how it works
um so on the night jesus was betrayed
he had one final meal with his disciples
and at one point during that meal he
stood up in their midst
and he was holding up a loaf of bread
and then he broke it
and he said this is my body
you can go ahead and partake of the
bread
and then jesus took a cup from the table
and he held it up
and he said this this is
my blood
whenever you eat this bread whenever you
drink this cup
remember me
lord jesus thank you
thank you for the ways that you you call
us
um out of
that place of victimhood and not by
erasing
our past not by saying
oh it was actually great but but by
healing it and restoring it and
transfiguring it and doing a new thing
in us
thank you god thank you for your
faithfulness lord would you help us
live into that
[Music]
and i just lift up every person here
who's um
maybe just have has felt really defined
by their wounds
i pray that you would bring healing life
and light to them
god set us free set us free
we love you lord in the powerful
life-changing name of jesus i pray
amen
[Music]
you guys feel free to join in with us as
we sing this last song
just acknowledging that
that we want to do the things that allow
us to grow
we want to step in to the identity that
jesus
has for us that calls us forward
i could just say
i could just sit away for all your
goodness
hope to feel your presence
i could just stay
i could just stay right where i am and
hope to
feel you hope to feel something again
i could hold on
i could hold on to who i am and
never let you change me from the
inside i could be safe
oh i could be safe here in your arms and
never
leave home never let these walls down
but you have called me
higher you have called me
deeper and i'll go where you will lead
me lord
you have called me higher you
have called me deeper and i'll go where
you
will lead me lord for you
lead me
[Music]
you lead me lord
you lead me
[Music]
you lead me lord
i could hold on i could hold on to
who i am and never let you
change me from the inside
i could be safe oh
i could be safe here in your arms and
never
leave home never let these walls down
but
you have called me higher
you have called me deeper and i'll go
where you
will lead me lord
you have called me higher you
have called me deeper and i'll go where
you
will lead me lord or you'll lead me
[Music]
and i'll go where you will lead me
lord oh you
have called me higher you have called me
deeper and i'll go where you
will lead me lord you'll lead
me
[Music]
you'll lead me lord
where you'll lead me
[Music]
you lead me lord
and i will be your soul
i will be yours for all my life
and i will be yours so
[Music]
i will be yours
life so let your mercy light the path
before me
you have called me higher you
have called me deeper and i'll go where
you will lead
[Music]
you have called me higher you
have called me deeper and i'll go where
you will lead
me lord oh
you have called me higher you
have called me deeper and i'll go where
you
will lead me lord
you have called me higher you
have called me deeper and i'll go where
you will lead
me lord you'll lead me
lead me lord
you'll lead me
[Music]
thank you so much for being with us
tonight what a great message
um a great worship um so glad you could
join us here and also to those of you
online
um as you go into your week ahead
take the words that you heard tonight to
heart and
i strongly encourage you to take some
quiet time
this week and ask god
god how do you see me who do you say
that i
am and just leave some space for that
and allow god to speak to your very
spirit the truth
of who you are um
and from experience i can tell you like
i've done that and it's rocked my world
and healed so much so please take that
time this week
also we're a community and we want to be
that for each other
so if you need prayer if you need a
shoulder to cry on to talk to
to listen please don't leave before
that that takes place also i can
understand
sometimes you don't want to come up
front you don't want to talk to anybody
right now
we have cards back on the little table
back there and also for those of you
online you can leave a comment you can
message us
reach out however you can we want to be
there for you
and thirdly if you guys would please
stand
i would love to bless you with this
benediction as you go
and i'm gonna keep saying this every
time i'm up here
because i don't think we can hear it too
often
you are a child of god
this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted
just as you are and go
filled with god's holy spirit and the
desire to extend
those gifts of unconditional love
and grace to everyone you come in
contact with
be blessed have a great week and we hope
to see you back here next sunday
[Music]
so
[Laughter]
[Music]
so
oh